semble garder un bien mauvais souvenir
de son dernier dossier en tant qu'avocat
du Premier ministre c'est lui qui a joué
les intermédiaires entre son chef de
cabinet
et l'avocat de Mike de fille pour
convaincre ce dernier de rembourser le
Sénat or il croit qu'on l'a tenu dans
l'ignorance c'était une situation
auditive dans laquelle je me sentais
pris au dépourvu
Niger Wright ne lui a pas rapporté par
exemple toutes ces conversations avec
Mike de fille même si Benjamen Perrin
échangeait au même moment plusieurs
courriels par jour avec l'avocat du
sénateur il n'a jamais parlé directement
au Premier ministre dans ce dossier et à
présumé par exemple que Steven Harper
connaissait le plan détaillé en 5 points
qui prévoyait entre autres que le parti
allait payer pour le sénateur quand
monsieur Rey était écrit en Alpes verts
a-t-il raconté en témoignage je pensais
que le premier ministre lui-même avait
directement approuvé il a exprimé ses
frustrations unigel Wright et aurait
voulu pouvoir donner le dossier à un
autre avocat comme avocat dans cette
affaire on m'a clairement tenu à l'écart
a-t-il dit mon client ne m'informait pas
des discussions avec l'autre partie ce
n'est pas la façon de mener un dossier
légal
après avoir affirmé sous serment jeudi
que contrairement à ce que soutient
l'entourage du chef conservateur rénovac
l'actuel chef de cabinet de Steven
Harper connaissait l'existence du fameux
chèque de 90 000 dollars cette portion
du témoignage met au jour un nouvel
aspect de la crise monsieur
un autre témoignage qui vient brouiller
la campagne conservatrice alors qu'à
l'instar d'une [__] les libéraux
réclament eux aussi une nouvelle enquête
de la GRC et malgré ce sondage qui dit
que plus de 60% des Canadiens ne croient
plus le premier ministre Stephen Harper
lui ne dérange pas son discours
après
un autre ex employé du bureau du premier
ministre doit prendre la barre Chris
Woodcock était responsable de la gestion
des enjeux durant la crise son
témoignage commence lundi et si Daniel
Thibault Radio-Canada Ottawa